[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM HOCKIN: Welcome, everybody.
Thank you for coming today.
Glad to see a nearly full room.
My name is Tim, I'm one of the
tech leads on the Kubernetes
project.
MIKE RUBIN: My
name is Mike Rubin,
I'm a tech lead and
manager in Kubernetes also.
TIM HOCKIN: We're here
today to talk to you
about networking in Kubernetes,
specifically in Google Cloud.
I hope that by the
end of today, you'll
all realize that
this is not nearly as
scary or complicated as it
sounds, or maybe I'm wrong.
So let's start.
The point of Kubernetes
is to run clusters, right?
A cluster is natively,
a networked construct.
It is fundamentally
about machines
that talk to each other.
Because of that, we have to
take networking really seriously
from the very beginning.
You can't think about--
you can't comprehend
Kubernetes, what we're doing,
without really
understanding the network.
It's really easy
to get overwhelmed
when we talk about Kubernetes.
There's a lot of new terms.
Everybody here is probably
familiar with basic TCIP
networking.
We're going to build
on that knowledge,
but there's a lot
of new concepts
that we need to bring in.
Things like name spaces,
and virtual interfaces,
and forwarding, and IP tables.
We are going to demystify
that today for you, I hope.
So we don't really
have a lot of time
to do a Kubernetes 101 today.
So if you want to talk
about how Kubernetes works
and the basic constructs,
I'm happy to talk to people
afterwards, or you can find us
on GitHub, talk to me on email.
But I do want to run through
a couple of background topics
that we're going to touch
on today during our talk,
because I think it's important
that everybody understand
these basics when we
talk about these words.
So the first term I'm going to
introduce is our API server.
Kubernetes is a very
API centric system.
The API server is the
center of our universe.
Everything in our system
talks to the API server.
Our API a REST API.
The R in REST is
for resource, so we
tend to talk about
our API concepts
in terms of
resources or objects.
They mean the same thing.
It's really just a
serialized blob of data
that we store on our
server that represents
a concept in our system.
So API server is at the
center of everything.
The second concept I want
to introduce is a pod.
Hopefully, if you
know Kubernetes,
you know what a pod is.
It is a very little,
tiny VM like thing,
that runs your containers.
It is a group of containers
that we schedule together.
It is the atom of Kubernetes.
When the containers in
a pod start and stop,
the pods still exists.
When you delete the pod, all
the containers go away together.
The interesting part here is
one of the fundamental pieces
of a pod is the network.
Everything inside of a
pod shares a network.
They all see each
other as local hosts,
they are the same
IP address, right.
This is really important.
The next concept to
introduce, controller.
So a controller is fundamentally
how Kubernetes is built.
It is basically
just a piece of code
that runs in a loop that
watches our API server
and responds to changes, right.
So, for example,
when you create a pod
you want to schedule
something in our system.
The scheduler wakes up.
The scheduler is a controller.
The scheduler makes a
decision about where
its going to put the
pod, it writes something
back the API server.
The cubelet wakes up.
The cubelet is a controller.
These are a fundamental
concept that we
are going to build on over
and over throughout this talk.
The main job of a
controller is to make
the reality match the intent.
You declare what
you want it to do,
and we are going
to make it happen.
So, a label.
Our API is full of these
resources, these objects.
A label is a tiny little
piece of metadata,
string to string
mapping key value,
that you can attach any
one of our API servers.
And you can attach any
number of these things
to our API objects.
These are used for
you to group things
however you want to group them.
We cannot possibly predict
how people are going to want
to use, to group, to
slice and dice our API,
so we provided a really
generic mechanism here.
This is fundamentally the
only grouping construct
in Kubernetes.
We're going to build on this
when we talk about services
and when we talk
about endpoints.
Similar to labels is
something called annotations.
An annotation is
the same structure,
but unlike a label, which we
tend to use for identification,
we tend to use annotation
for third party pieces
to carry extra information
about an object.
So the counterpart to
labels is selectors.
A label declares
what something is,
a selector declares how you're
going to use the thing, right.
So if you're a SQL
head, think of it
as select pods where
some condition.
This gives us a
really loose coupling
between concepts in our system.
It means that you, as a
user, can manage groups
however you want to manage
them, however you want to slice
and dice them.
For example, things that
used selectors, or services,
deployments, replica sets.
So a quick example
of a selector.
So imagine I've got my
application here running.
I've got-- they're
all part of my store,
but I've got some front ends,
and I've got some back ends,
and I've got some
production services,
and I've got some test services.
So I can select, with a
very simple selector, all
of my store pods that are
a part of the front end,
but I can also select
all my store pods
that are part of
my testing, right.
So you can see here how I
can select it anyway I want.
Now I could add another
label, and I could add
another dimension of selection.
And you can do this
arbitrarily, however
you need to do to manage
your applications.
So similarly, I could just
select the whole thing.
MIKE RUBIN: So let's talk
about the IP-per-pod model.
Tim said earlier, that
every pod is going
to have its own IP address.
There's a lot of different
ways to do networking
in-- with respect to containers.
Docker chooses to
use-- we don't choose
to use a lot of complexity.
We want to rely in Kubernetes
on a lot of old concepts
and traditional ideas involving
routing and networking.
There's no machine private
IPs, no port mapping.
Every pod has an
IP address and it's
accessible to all
the other pods,
just like every virtual
machine or real machine
has an IP address
and it's easiest
when it's accessible to all
of the other network entities
that you've got in your network.
We're going to be
using-- in Kubernetes,
we're going to show you how
this works, Linux network name
spaces, and virtual
interfaces in order
to implement the schema.
So here's a VM,
represented with a box.
Most computer
diagrams are boxes,
when you see another box.
The VM is going to have
a ethernet device, eth0,
and this is normally how you
think of network traffic coming
in and out of your machine.
Now, in truth, there's this root
namespace, network namespace,
that we associate with the
ethernet device for Linux,
and this has settings
for TCP/IP stack, perhaps
other data structures associated
with the Linux kernel that
are the context and environment
for your network environment
on the virtual machine.
What we want to do is have a
pod with its own environment.
We give it the
illusion that it's
living inside its own space, and
that it's on its own machine.
So we create a network
namespace for that pod.
The first pod, so we're going to
label it the really imaginative
name pod1.
Now we have a virtual
machine with two environments
that you can run
your application in,
each one believing that they're
inside their own network
namespace.
Problem here is networks are
useful when they can talk
to each other, right
now, these can't.
Here we can bring up the
idea of a virtual ethernet
device for Linux.
It's really just a pipe pair,
data will come in one side
and come out the other.
We want these two namespaces
to talk to each other.
So we take the pipe pair, and
using again some basic Linux
tools, we can have the pipe
pair span the namespaces.
Inside the root namespace, we
can give it any name we want,
and we'll call it virtual
ethernet device xx.
And inside the pod1,
we give it zero
so it looks like it's inside
its own virtual machine.
We can do this as
many times as we want.
Here we have two pods on the
same virtual machine, each one
believing that they're running
inside their own context
and they're talking
to the root namespace.
This is a step forward.
But we really want them
to talk to each other.
So we introduce the
concept of a bridge.
The bridge is, again,
something that you've
been using in networking for
decades, L2 level routing,
generally using
the ARP protocol.
I hope that most of you
are familiar with this,
it's pretty old, standard stuff.
You can Google it and
find out lots of tools
associated with it today.
So let's take a look now
at traffic moving from pod
to pod inside the same node.
Pod1 wants to send a message to
pod2, so it has an IP packet.
Source IP is pod1 and
it's going to pod2.
It leaves the pod1's
network namespace,
goes through the pipe pair, hits
the virtual ethernet device,
gets into the root namespace,
then goes to the bridge,
uses all the ARP
logic and technology
to find the right virtual
ethernet destination.
And then, once it gets to
the top of its pipe pair,
goes right through the
pipe pair and ends up
in pod2's namespace.
It's pretty straightforward,
pretty simple,
and using basic
concepts that, if you're
familiar with just
rudimentary networking,
should feel familiar to you.
So pods have to b e reachable
across VMs also, not just
inside of one VM.
Kubernetes itself doesn't
care how you do this.
You can use L2, L3, overlay,
carrying pigeons, unicorns,
[AUDIO OUT] matter, but there
has to be some standard way
to do this stuff.
Every VM is given an
IP block, and every pod
is given an IP address
inside that block.
So one thing we have to do
for Google Container Engine
is teach the network how to
route packets in-between VMs.
So, luckily, we have Tim here,
he knows all about this stuff,
and he's going to show us.
TIM HOCKIN: So
building on the image
that we looked at before, these
are the same sorts of machines,
only now we've got two
of them and they're
connected to our network.
So as Michael mentioned, we
have to teach the network
how to do this routing.
So what happens when
we send a packet out
of pod1 destined for pod4?
All right, same as before,
it's going to leave the pod,
it's going to enter
the root namespace,
we're going to hit the bridge.
Now, the ARP is going
to fail on that bridge.
There's nobody on
that bridge who's
answering this IP
address, so it's
going to send it out
the default route.
The default route, in
this case, is eth0.
So we send it out the default
route, it leaves the VM,
and it enters Google
Cloud's network.
And it promptly goes nowhere.
It goes nowhere because we have
anti-spoofing protection built
into Google Cloud,
and the network
knows that this VM
has an IP address
and the source IP is not
the right IP address.
So we have to set up
a couple of things
before we can make
any this work.
So the first thing we do,
when we create a VM, we tell
GCP that these are
all routers, right.
And the routers have a flag
called --can-ip-forward,
which means that it's allowed to
disable anti-spoof protection,
but for only for this VM.
The rest of the network
is still spoof safe.
Then we add a single static
route per VM, which says,
hey, if you see any packets
bound for this IP range,
send it over to the VM, and
the VM will know what to do.
Right.
The GCP network
handles the rest.
So let's go back here, we've
got this packet, it's from pod1,
it's going to pod4, right.
This time it passes through
the network successfully,
and it's delivered
to the second VM,
and the packet flows
in the exact same way
that we looked at before.
There's nothing
special here, there's
no translations required,
there's no encapsulation,
there's no overlays,
it just flows
the way a network should flow.
MIKE RUBIN: So one other thing
that's important to remember,
we just talked about
network namespace set up,
and virtual ethernet
device set up,
and all of these areas in
GCloud to turn off spoofing.
It's all automatically
handled for you
in Google Container Engine.
You don't have to
go to the man pages
and learn all of these pieces,
you just turn on the system
and by default, as you start
creating pods and creating--
these things will
just be set up.
But let's get back
to progressing
through the network stack inside
of Google Container Engine.
How do we deal with change?
Your cluster is a
living, dynamic system.
Sometimes you're going
to want to scale it up,
as load increases, or are you're
going to want to scale it down,
possibly, as low
decreases, or maybe revenue
becomes more of an interesting
issue in your life.
Rolling updates, you're going
to want to turn off some pods
and then turn them on
again with new software.
You're going to
want the pods, maybe
if they crash or hang to be
unscheduled and rescheduled
somewhere else, maybe
the VM is rebooting.
All of these events involve your
pod getting a new IP address,
and keeping track of all
of these IP addresses,
it's a lot of work.
You know, I have to start
keeping track of state,
and anyone who's
kept track of state
knows that it's never fun.
So you want to find a way
to have your systems network
traffic be able to
find the pods that you
care about without a lot
of work on your behalf.
Google Container Engine helps
you with this, with services.
Dun dun dun!
The service abstraction--
it's an abstraction
and another resource
or object that
lives inside the API server.
It's basically a mapping
of a cluster IP address
or a virtual IP address to a
group of endpoints, usually
pods.
It provides you a
stable VIP, and the VIP,
when you send traffic to it,
will then route that traffic
to the pods that are being
selectively associated
with that service.
We're going to examine the
default implementation of this
in Google Container Engine.
But like many things in
Google Container Engine,
you can always componentized
it and try to do something else
if that's really what you need.
The set of the pods behind a
service can change dynamically,
and it doesn't really matter,
as long as you have that VIP,
your traffic can
reach those pods.
So let's try to
create a service.
Here's the yaml.
The fields that really matter
is the name, in this case,
we're going to call it
the store-be for maybe all
the store backend pods.
And this selector here says
application that matches store,
and the roles that
are the backend.
So the selector
field here is going
to then find all of the
pods, that with these labels,
and associate them
with this service.
What you get back
is some information
from Kubernetes API's server.
It's going to automatically
create a distributed load
balancer for you, and it's also
going to allocate this cluster
IP 10.9.3.76.
And this is the IP address
that within the cluster,
any traffic to
that IP address is
going to make sure it
reaches one of those pods,
and it's going to smear
this traffic over randomly
and fairly.
The idea here is
that it's balanced
across all of those pods.
Now I'm going to take a slight
digression, because this word
is a very accurate
word in this context,
but it's overloaded
in networking
and sometimes in Kubernetes.
The idea of what is an
Endpoints resource or object
in the API server.
As we said earlier, every
time you create a service,
you're also having to select
the pods that are associated
with that service
that the traffic is
going to be routed
to, and you have
a selector associated with it.
Well, when you create a service
in Google Container Engine,
you also have Google
Container Engine for you
create an endpoints resource or
object with the same selector.
So if you have a bunch of
pods that you associated
with that service, in this
case, app: store role: be,
well, they're going to be
found by the endpoints--
the Kubernetes system,
which will associate them
with the endpoints, and it's
going to automatically create
for you this endpoints object.
And why do we need this?
Well, it turns out that in
Google Container Engine,
and in Kubernetes in
general and open source
also, a lot of objects
and controllers
really want to know about
all of the pods associated
with a service.
And they make this query
over and over and over again,
and it's an expensive query.
So as an implementation
detail, we've
decided in Google
Container Engine
to create a resource just for
this mapping of service name
to pod IP addresses.
This way, as pods
come and go, we
have a convenient
cache of the locations
and IP addresses for
all of these pods.
The-- [AUDIO OUT]
makes this kind of--
coming in and out--
[AUDIO OUT] in, out, much
like a pod going up and down.
Only thing that makes
this really interesting
and sometimes confusing is
it has the name Endpoints,
and we have HTTP Endpoints, and
we have a lot of other network
terms that refer to endpoints.
That's the only reason
we brought it up today.
It confused me.
It took me like two
months to realize
exactly what we were
talking about when
we started with the project.
Let's take a look
now at the life
of a packet from the
pod to a service.
Looks very familiar to
what we've seen before.
It's a pod, and--
should I move, or is this good?
OK.
The packet leaves the pod.
Source IP address is
the pod, and what's
different now is the
destination IP address is
going to the service,
in this case, service 1.
Goes from the network namespace
to the pipe, hits the bridge,
but instead of going
to another pod,
it's going to instead
go to IP tables.
In IP tables, we're
going to do a DNAT.
And the DNAT's going to take
that destination service,
and remember, service is just
a handle to a group of pods.
It's going to take that service,
and pick the pod that we
want this packet to go to.
In this case, pod99, and
it's going to use a system
called Conntrack to remember
which pod it sent this IP--
this connection of
traffic to Conntrack.
Conntrack is
another Linux system
that does connection
tracking for you.
It bases it on the
5-tuple of IP header
that you're sending
the traffic out to,
and it does a lot of
other things, too,
but it's going to remember
where it came from
or where the initial
destination was.
We're going to
see how it's being
used for Kubernetes networking
as we continue the talk.
So now we have rewritten
the destination IP address
for pod99, or IP tables
has done the load balancing
on this machine to take
our traffic instead
of to the service
IP, to the actual pod
that the service
is fronting for us.
And then when that
pod has responded,
it comes back,
coming from pod99,
saying I want to
go back to pod1.
It hits the IP tables.
The IP tables uses
Conntrack [AUDIO OUT]
--uses Conntrack to
[AUDIO OUT] the packet,
rewrites the source IP header
from pod99 to service 1.
Sorry, we're having some
audio stuff going on.
Is this cool?
OK, I'll continue.
And then it goes
on its merry way,
just like we've described
a few times already,
all the way back to the
pod1's network namespace.
So let's take a little
more look at the IP tables.
The IP table rules, if
you look at them raw,
are really, really
scary, but this
is some of the things you
really have to remember when you
look at services and IP tables.
The IP tables are really
performing one piece of logic.
They're trying to route
that packet and the traffic
in general to the pods
behind the service.
So they check to see
the destination IP
and the port match the
service's [AUDIO OUT] port,
and if they do, they're going
to pick one of the backends
at random and then
rewrite the destination
and send that connection on its
way to that appropriate pod.
Now here's something else
that's kind of funny,
and a lot of people
have asked about.
All of this work is happening
within the Linux kernel.
We are not copying the data out
of the kernel into userspace,
playing with the packets,
and then sending it
back into userspace again.
It's really inefficient,
it's really not the right way
to do it, but it is
the way, when we first
began working on Kubernetes
in Google Container Engine,
it is how things used to work.
And this is just sort of
getting things off the ground
and prototyping.
So because of that,
the system and the pod
that actually maintains
all of these IP table rules
is called the cube
proxy, because it
used to be a proxy for
all this network traffic.
It's not actually a proxy
today, all it does is--
just talk into it?
Can I sing and dance?
All right, great.
TIM HOCKIN: I don't
know, can you?
MIKE RUBIN: No, I can't
sing, nor can I dance.
Thank you, Tim.
TIM HOCKIN: My pleasure.
MIKE RUBIN: So-- cube proxy.
Cube proxy is a pod that
lives on every node,
and it maintains these
IP table rules for you.
It used to do this
in user space, which
is why it has a name
that's very confusing,
but now it just maintains
the IP table rules
that keep the services running.
It's a controller,
just like many
of the other pieces of
Kubernetes infrastructure,
and it watches the API
for services changes,
and when they change it's
going to update the IP
tables for you.
So let's go take a look at
life of a packet from pod
to service.
Right now, the source is
going to come to the service
and destination's
going to a pod.
Destination is
coming to the pod--
oh wait, I'm in
the wrong button.
TIM HOCKIN: Yeah.
MIKE RUBIN: Between the
mic and the singing,
it's way too much fun.
Services.
DNS is just another
service inside
of Google Container Engine,
that's how we implemented it.
You don't really want to
hard code the name and IP--
you want to hard
code the IP address
of all of these
services into your code.
But, if you know the
name of the service,
you may want to hard code
the name of the service
to direct your traffic to
all of the pods associated
with that service.
So Google Container
Engine will automatically,
when you create that service,
put the service's name
inside the DNS space inside
the Google Container Engine.
It uses normal A
and SRV records,
so you don't really
have to do anything,
and DNS itself runs as
a pod and as a service
for you, just using the same
infrastructure that we're
asking people to use.
DNS service has got a little
bit of extra magic and sugar.
Just like, other services,
things that we can show you.
Any service-- and we
just used this for DNS--
can request a
particular cluster IP.
So we know what DNS, we want to
use the IP address 10.0.0.10.
So we specify that when
we create the service,
and we know that we're going
to get that IP address.
We'll get an error when
we create the service.
Also something special
about DNS is it's auto
scaled to the cluster size.
It's actually a ratio
of nodes versus cores,
but the idea here
is we don't really
ever want DNS to be overloaded.
Google Container Engine has
a little bit more surprise
and fun and adventure
when we do that,
so we auto scale it to keep
things running correctly.
Again, just like other services,
the [INAUDIBLE] is stable.
Services are simple
and powerful.
You can use any
port you want, you
don't have to worry
about conflicts.
You can request a
particular cluster IP,
as we just described,
and you can remap ports.
That's all there
really is to it.
The big thing to
remember, again,
is services are an abstraction.
They're an idea of mapping of
a name and IP address to pods
that lives and you can
manage in the API server,
but the implementation
of it is kind of
spread across all the
IP tables and maintained
by cube proxy inside of
Google Container Engine.
It doesn't really have
one running process that's
doing all of this
work, but all you
need to know as a
customer and a client
is you set up the service,
you hit the client IP address
or you hit that DNS
name, and that's
really all you have to handle.
Google Container
Engine takes care
of all this complexity for you.
Let's talk about sending
external traffic.
What if you want to take traffic
outside of your GCP project
to the outside world?
Egress.
VMs all get private IPs in
the 10.0.0.0/8 IP range,
and VMs can also get public IPs.
When they get a public IP,
they get one public IP mapped
to one private IP.
So let's look at
the life of a packet
from going from VM
to the internet.
Here we have our same
happy virtual machine,
with the root namespace zero
device inside a GCP project.
We send a packet out with
the VM internal's IP address.
The source going to 8.8.8.8.
And then in the NAT
subsystem of the GCP project,
we rewrite the internal
address to the external,
so the external internet knows
where this packet came from
and can route it back.
And away we go.
And then, because 8.8.8.8 is
maintained by this fabulously
happy company, comes
back really fast,
and we go back to the
VM external address.
Also, for those of you who
are not in the audience,
there's one person laughing at
my jokes, which is really cool.
We rewrite the
external IP address
to the internal IP address.
It's not really a big deal, it's
normal routing, like always.
But what happens with the pod?
Everything's a little different.
Just like always, the pod
comes from the root namespace,
comes up to the device,
hits the bridge,
comes out through the VM,
the source here-- sorry,
glanced over that.
The source here is the pod
IP address, hits the NAT,
[BUZZER NOISE], it's dropped.
The one-to-one NAT inside
the GCP, for security,
only really understands and
allows VM IPs to get out.
The pod IP it is not equal
to VM IP, so it gets dropped.
When in doubt,
what's the answer?
IP tables.
And so here we MASKERADE
again, or use Source NAT,
and we apply this to any packet
with a destination that's
outside of the internal
cluster's IP range.
So let's take a quick
look at that again.
Life of a packet,
pod to internet,
we go all the way
up to the IP tables.
We rewrite the pod1 source to
the VM internal IP address,
it leaves the VM, it goes
to the NAT subsystem.
Now we rewrite it again,
from VM internal to external,
just as before.
Goes to 8.8.8.8,
comes right back,
we rewrite the destination,
external to internal, just
as before, hits the
ethernet device,
goes into the IP tables, we use
Conntrack in the same system
that we built all this
logic on, to now we
write it with the
pod1's IP address.
And by now, I hope some of
you are tired of this path
as we go back to the
pod1 network namespace.
Tim?
TIM HOCKIN: So that gives
you a pretty good picture
of how packets move around
within your GCP cluster, right?
And that was super cool,
but it's not really
that interesting,
because most of us
have to deal with
the outside world.
And getting out to
GitHub is cool and all,
but it's not going
to sell your product.
You've got to take
traffic in, right?
This is a really
complicated problem.
For Kubernetes in
general, we have
to build it to the
particular platforms
that you're running on.
So Kubernetes is on
GCP is going to rely
on a couple of
different GCP products
to bring traffic
into the cluster.
And we're going to see
how we use those products.
So in particular, we,
for the Kubernetes API,
where we set a
type load balancer,
we're going to use Google's
Network Load Balancer at L4.
And where we use the
ingress resource,
we're going to use the L7 load
balancer, the HTTP and HTTPS
load balancer.
So let's look at L4
first, because it's
the less exciting one.
So we looked at
service earlier, right,
Michael mentioned cluster IPs.
So we're going to change
the type from a cluster IP
to a load balancer.
Now the way we've
set this up is these
are sort of concentric, so
cluster IP, node port load
balancer.
So load bouncer still
is a cluster IP.
It's still going to
get allocated an IP
address within my
cluster, but what
happens when I set this, is
another controller wakes up--
this is our Google Cloud
controller-- it wakes up
and it says, hey I know
what to do with that.
I'm going to go off and I'm
going to create a Google Load
Balancer, and I'm going
to set up all the routing,
and I'm going to
make it work for you.
So when it's done
with that, it's
going write back to the service
you have a load balancer,
and it's ingress point is
this IP address, right.
So now you, as an end user,
you can take that IP address.
You can stick it in your
DNS, you can share it
with your customers, you can
write it on the bathroom wall,
people will find your store.
So let's look at how this
works, like, in practice.
So we have a cluster here,
and to make things fun,
this cluster has three VMs.
One VM happens to have
one of my particular pod,
one VM has none,
and one VM has two.
So now I create that service
with type load balancer,
this controller wakes
up, and goes off
and it creates a Google
Network Load Balancer.
If anybody is really familiar
with the Google Cloud API,
this is a forwarding
rule, right.
It's going to create
a forwarding rule,
and it's going to
point that forwarding
rule at all of my VMs.
And this means we don't ever
have to update the forwarding
rule, except if the VMs
change, because that's
sort of a slow API.
So we program it and
program to all of these VMs.
So now, user has
found our store,
and they're going to
send us some traffic.
The packet here from the
client to the load balancer,
this is important.
Now we go through
this load balancer,
and the load balancer
has to make a decision.
It looks at all of the VMs
that are eligible to be chosen,
it's going to pick
one of these three.
In this case, we're
going to pick VM1.
It doesn't really matter
which one we choose,
because the same flow is going
to happen in all of them.
So now we send a packet on to--
shoot, we have a firewall.
All right, so the
first thing that we're
going to do,
automatically, is we're
going to run GCloud
Firewalls create,
we're going to open up the
firewall for you on that port
so that the load balancer
can now talk to your service.
So now this packet comes
through this firewall--
or comes through
the load balancer,
and it enters your GCP network.
This is the coolest part
Google's network load
balancer is not a proxy,
it's a packet forwarder.
So when this packet
comes into your network,
the destination address is
still the load balancer,
and the client of
the source address
is still the original client.
So you can examine
that IP packet
and figure out who sent
you this traffic, right.
That's pretty neat, and
it's really important.
And I'm going to mess
it up in just a second.
So this packet arrives at a VM,
and we bring it into this VM,
the source and destinations
are unchanged from before.
Now hold on a second.
I said that it doesn't matter
which VM you land on, right,
but clearly, one of these VMs
would be a bad choice, right.
The load balancer, like
all of the cloud load
balancers as we go through
this container revolution,
they only know about VMs, right.
VMs don't map one
to one with pods.
We have more pods then we
do VMs, or we have less pods
than we do VMs, or we
have the same number
but they just don't
happen to map correctly.
We call this the
imbalance problem, right.
Imagine for a minute
that I actually
set it up so that it only
sent traffic to these two VMs,
And we ignored the one that
has no backends, right.
I'm going to send 50%
of the traffic here,
of my traffic here.
That seems completely reasonable
from the load balancer's point
of view, since it doesn't know
that there's more VMs on one
than on the other.
So at the end, what
you get is one pod
that has 50% of your
traffic and two pods
that have 25% of your traffic.
Whatever monitoring
system you're going to use
is going to go nuts,
right, it's not
going to know what
to do with this.
It's not going to know how
to scale your application,
and your ops team is
going to hate you.
I mean, they probably already
do, but they'll hate you more.
So this is the general
imbalance problem.
So we set out with
the initial design
to not trigger the
imbalance problem.
So how do we avoid
the imbalance?
We squirt some IP
tables onto it.
IP tables is the caulk
of networking systems,
you squirt it in
wherever there's
a gap to fill in and
smooth things over.
So this packet
comes into this VM,
and we're going to
consider which pod am
I going to send it to, right.
This is the same path that
we saw before, only now
it's coming in from
outside, and we
have to consider all of the pods
across all of the VMs, right.
So in this case, we're going
to choose pathologically,
and we're going to pick a
pod on a different VM, right.
So I'm going to
send this packet--
first of all, first I'm
doing to do a destination
NAT, which we saw before.
This is literally the same
set of IP tables rules.
So don't think of these
things as additive,
they are really the
same set of logic.
I'm going to do my
destination NAT.
I'm going to send
the packet out,
now note the address
here has changed,
the definition of says pod2,
but the original is still
the client, the source IP.
And I'm going forward
this packet down,
and it's going to
land at the second VM,
and just like before it's
going to arrive at this pod.
We're going to respond.
We're sending back from
pod2 to our client,
and because it's
from pod2 the client,
it's going to go
out to the internet.
It actually will through that
NAT thing that Michael just
talked about, but it's going
to be up to the client,
and it's going to get dropped.
Why does it get dropped?
Well, the client sent a
packet to the load balancer,
it didn't send a packet
to this pod or this VM,
and so this TCP session isn't
going to complete, right.
So let's rewind for a minute,
back to when that packet first
arrived at the first VM.
We have to do a second NAT,
which is the source NAT.
We have to change the source
IP to be from this VM.
I'm forcing the first VM
to be in the traffic path
in order to achieve
my balancing.
So now, when you see this
packet fly across the network,
the source is VM1 and
the destination is pod2.
All that cool stuff about
keeping the client IP address
from the network load balancer?
I just frittered away.
But just wait, there's more.
So-- there's more IP tables--
the packet's going to
arrive at the second VM
the same way we saw before.
It's going to be
delivered to the pod,
it's going to come
back, no problem.
Conntrack is going
to wake up, realize
that it has to un-NAT
this packet twice,
and then it's going
to respond back up.
The load balancer
will return it,
and it will merrily go on
its way to your customer.
Phew.
That is a little complicated.
So that imbalance problem,
it's a real problem,
and we chose to avoid it, right.
Now, the good news is
that in practice, we're
really well-balanced.
The bad news is you have
that extra network hop, which
can cause some extra
network latency,
and it hides this client
from the user's backend.
It turns out,
surprise, users want
to make this choice
for themselves.
So--
MIKE RUBIN: Dun
dun dun, how do you
deal with this network problem?
Only local.
Not just IP tables, we're
going to apply an annotation.
What are the problems that
we're trying to resolve here?
Well, sometimes some of
the customers, as Tim
said, they would rather
risk the imbalance
or find a way to provision
around the imbalance,
and they really care about
getting the client IP address.
They know-- it's a big deal.
And also they don't want
to deal with the double--
the latency issues.
So in Google Containers Engine,
we now support only local.
You can apply the annotation
only local onto the service,
and we're going to go
see how that works, too.
Again, this is all being set
up for you automatically.
What only local
does is it's going
to make sure that when you
make that routing selection,
the VM that you pick
is the local one.
So as Tim said earlier, the
imbalance here is across VMs,
were balanced OK.
We're going to have VM1 versus
VM3 is where the pods live.
We have a health check to
let us know not to go to VM2.
But, when you go and check
out the pods below that,
we can end up with
this imbalance.
If we have a lot
more pods and nodes,
this isn't that really
that big an issue.
It's just sort of noise
for the imbalance,
if you have 1,000 pods and
let's say only four nodes,
it doesn't really matter.
If you have many, many
more nodes and pods,
well, all of those
pods are going
to be singletons on
the nodes or the VMs,
and so you're not going to
have an imbalance either,
between the health
checks you're always
going to have a
nice distribution
at that first level or
the network load balancer
is doing the balancing to VMs.
Get into problems when
you have situations
like this, where the number of
pods and the number of nodes
are about the same.
And then the level of--
like Tim said, you
can have some issues
where the load that your
pods are dealing with
are not going to be uniform.
So with only local on,
the traffic comes in,
as we said earlier,
the health check
is not going to consider VM2.
Source IP address is the client,
destination is load balancer.
We can choose VM1, VM3,
we're going to pick VM3,
because it's more
fun and interesting.
VM1, also fun, maybe
not as much interesting.
We go to VM3, source
client, destination LB.
And then when we get on
VM3, we hit the IP tables,
and remember, the IP
tables could send you
to anywhere that's
going to have that pod.
But in this case,
with only local,
it is only going to send you to
a pod that is local to this VM.
It's only going to consider
pod2 and pod3, clearly marked
in green.
Bright, emerald green.
It goes to pod2, it easily
could have gone to pod3,
but we just chose
pod2 for this session.
[INAUDIBLE] the DNAT, reaches
pod2, and then goes back
through the same NATing
and Conntracking and IP
tabling path that we've
discussed over and over again
during this talk.
Comes all the way back out
to the node load balancer,
and then back to the client.
And as a result,
what's really important
here is that your pod, the code
that your developers wrote,
or maybe you wrote, is going to
be able to see the client's IP
address.
You're not going to play
these games of not knowing
where the packet came from.
You get the normal expected
path that makes the most sense.
Ingress.
TIM HOCKIN: Righto.
So now you all have
internalized exactly how
Kubernetes works at layer 4.
So let's talk about
Layer 7, because that's
way more interesting, right.
There's been a couple of really
good talks here this week
about some of the
cool stuff that's
happening in the Layer 7 space.
To bring up Layer 7, we
have a different kind
of resource in Kubernetes,
called an ingress.
Ingress is built on
top of services, so--
ingress.
The first thing you need to
do is change your service
to a node port.
Now you could use--
remember I said earlier you
have cluster IP, node port, load
balancer.
You could use load balancer
if you want in L4 also,
but generally people will
say I only want the L7.
So I set it up as
type node port.
What node port does
is it tells Kubernetes
allocate me a port,
the same port,
on every VM in my
cluster, and make
sure that that port
forwards onto my service.
How do we forward onto
that service, everybody?
IP tables.
So-- again, literally it's
the same exact code path
that we followed before.
So you declare this thing
as a type node port,
and then you introduce
an ingress object.
The ingress object represents
a higher level concept,
it's an L7 HTTP load balancer.
And the cool thing about
HTTP load balancers
is they have the understanding
of what you're actually
doing at the application level.
So things like a URL can
map to a different service.
So in this case,
you can see like,
the world's simplest ingress
has a /customers URL,
and that customer's URL is going
to go to our customers backend,
and the /products URL is going
to go to our products backend,
right.
Each of these two backends
are different services,
which are backed
by a set of pods,
through this selector
mechanism that we've been
seeing over and over again.
So you can see here, sorry,
I just highlighted that.
So, again, just like a
service, when you do this,
the controller wakes up.
The controller goes out to
Google Cloud and it programs
the HTTP load balancer.
Again, if anybody's familiar
with the Google Cloud API,
the HTTP load balancer is
actually about eight resources
to the Google Cloud API.
It's sort of complicated to set
up because it's so incredibly
powerful.
We take that for you,
we do it all for you,
we configure the instance
groups and the backends,
and the forwarding rules
and the target proxies.
We set it all up,
and in the end,
we point your IP address here.
Again, you can take
this IP address,
you can put it in your
DNS, and off to the races.
So let's take a look
at some traffic again.
So we've got a
cluster, we've got
our blue and green services,
our customers and our products.
These ports exist on every node,
so when you create that ser--
the ingress object, we're going
to go off and create the Google
Cloud Load Balancer.
Google Cloud Load
Balancer, as before, we
teach it about all three VMs
through the instance group
mechanism, and we start
taking our traffic.
So, our client sends
something to our load balancer
on the /products path,
that's the green one.
We're going to take
the packet through,
and again, the load
balancer has to choose,
which VM am I going
to send this to.
It's going to look at
all the information
that it has available to it,
and it's going to choose a VM.
In this case it's
going to choose VM3.
Now I said that we're
looking at the green service
and I chose three to
sort of the pessimal.
It's going to send
this traffic off
to the VM now take note
here of the IP addresses
the source here is
the load balancer.
But it's not actually the IP
address of the load balancer
that you had, it's sort of
a Google internal address
that we use for all of
our load balancing pool.
We've published
docs on this range
that we use for
a load balancers.
This is because our HTTP load
balancer is a full proxy,
right, it will terminate
your TCP session.
So you could do things
like SSL, where you give us
your certificate, we'll
terminate the SSL,
and we'll pass the
packets onto the back.
What it means is you lose
that client IP again,
but you don't actually lose
it, because this is HTTP,
and HTTP is so cool because
it's got things like headers.
So the client IP
address will be stuck
in that X forwarded for
header, which you can then
use if any piece of your
stack understands HTTP,
you can pull that out
and log that correctly.
So now the packet
is destined for VM3.
So we've changed both the
source and the destination.
If we go back, you
see the packet here
is client to load balancer,
here it's load balancer to VM.
This packet is going to
arrive at the greenport.
And this is
important, because we
use the receipt
at that greenport
as a trigger to say,
hey, I know what to do
with this, this a service.
And I'm going to send it--
oh shoot, I'm going to
send it to IP tables again.
Same thing we've
seen six times now.
IP tables is going
to choose a pod,
it's going to do that NAT
that we saw before, it's
going to bounce
out of the machine,
it's going to fly
over our network,
we're going to receive it,
no tricks this time, it's
actually going to work, and
it's going to come back.
Now we've received
it in IP tables.
We do the opposite of that
contract that we saw before,
and we send the packet back on,
and we have a happy customer.
So it's even more
complicated than L4,
and it suffers some
of the same problems.
You've got this double
hop, still, right.
So, it turns out,
customers still
want to make this
decision for themselves.
MIKE RUBIN: So we don't have to
worry about losing the client's
IP address, but
as Tim just said,
the double hop is
still a problem
and it adds that complexity.
Everyone here can
see this slide,
it looks very similar to
the other only local side
for a service.
You can have inside of ingress
these sort of subservices based
on the path or the
annotations that you want,
and you can specify
only local again.
You can configure the
subservice inside the ingress
is only local, and you risk
the imbalance as before,
which can usually be avoided by
how you choose to apportion out
your nodes and pods, and
you remove the second hop.
So there's a lot more
that we could discuss.
I mean, I can just
read from the slide.
Pod liveness probe,
graceful termination,
cloud health checks, firewalls,
and so on and so forth.
But networking is really deep.
The functionality and
features that people want out
of Google Container Engine
for networking, the list
goes on and on and
on and on and on.
Instead of talking about
each one of these subtopics,
we really wanted to make
sure that people understood
the routing basics, both in
and out of the inter cluster--
intercluster ingress and egress.
And that's sort of what
we're hoping to do here.
I know that this got
a little repetitious,
but it's because we build and
don't waste the functionality
and infrastructure that we have
instead of Google Container
Engine.
TIM HOCKIN: Can I add--
I've spent the week
here working downstairs
at the Meet the Experts
table, and I've spoken to,
I know, some of you.
I have wanted to
pull these slides out
at least a dozen times
over the last two days
to explain concepts.
And so I thought it was
really important that we
get this information out there.
I get the sense from a lot of
people that this is complicated
and they don't understand it.
MIKE RUBIN: It's an interesting
talk, because by the end
you get a lot of OK, we've
got it, we've got it,
you reinforced it, but
then before the talk,
a lot of people
want to know exactly
about this sort of topic.
And so even instead of Google,
when we wrote this talk,
it's gotten a lot of interest.
Watch this space.
Google Container Engine is
definitely a moving target.
There's the open source
components and the open source
architecture, which
has been worked on
by companies and engineers
all over the world.
And, you know, lots
of rearchitecture,
and lots of just bug fixes and
elegant and simplifications
and development work is being
undergone, even as we speak.
Even Google, we're working on
the Google Container Engine
part as we host it and integrate
it with the GCP environment.
So Next '18, it's going
to look different.
It will be looking
maybe faster, maybe
less IP tables, for
some of the problems
that we just elaborated on.
Probably more IP tables for
new functionality and new
features, and different ways
to approach these problems.
So there will definitely
be more ins and outs,
and we hope that you come
back to learn more about it
next year.
If you want to know more
about what's going on
and not wait till next
year, because, you know,
who wants to wait, here's our
website for documentation.
You can look at the code right
now and start playing with it
and examining how
things work in detail.
If you wanted to ask
questions there's our chat
and here's our Twitter.
There's also a code
lab downstairs,
which we've been told not
enough people know about,
so please feel free to
get your hands dirty.
It's really the best way
to learn about anything,
and there are people there
who are willing to help
you get started.
Finally, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]